pittsburgh steelers hey they don't need
to do mock drafts usually because
they're drafting so low it doesn't
matter why waste your time you got to
see how the board falls out this year
they're still drafting fairly low and
one thing that kevin colbert said
yesterday chris is that the steelers are
absolutely open to drafting a
quarterback now i don't know what that
means like you know if a guy they really
love ends up falling into their laps how
do you say no to it but you know another
thing colbert said yesterday is
keeping ben rothersberger set the tone
for their offseason in other words as
we've said that's what the moment they
decided to go all in on this year so
why would you take a quarterback if
you're all in on this year that that
that's the big thing right with me i i
really do question that
listen i i could sit here and go through
mock drafts and do things
and and
come up with some reasonable scenarios
right where hey let's just say let's say
the panthers don't take a quarterback
the broncos don't take a quarterback
right
okay now
let's let's say one two three was let's
what we think lawrence zach wilson and
let's go mac jones right is three
trey lance gets eaten up by the falcons
whatever
like
where would justin fields fall to where
if he gets past the broncos at nine what
happens there i mean we know the
patriots maybe right i don't know i
don't know how they feel about that
there's the washington football team of
course that could have some need there
is washington going to take another ohio
state quarterback after just taking a
failed ohio state quarterback i don't
know about that either but once you get
past that little area you sit there and
go wait the next team up that logically
makes sense is pittsburgh
but that's where it's it's funny mike
and if you're pittsburgh at 24 and just
and there are 24 i believe right or 25
justin fields
is there
what would you do because of what you
just said i would think they're trying
to go all in one more time on big ben
you know do you take justin fields there
or not i don't know that'll be a tough
decision
yeah and if you don't take him that's a
great spot to trade out of that position
and then if not jay harris is the target
or some other running back you get him
at the top of round two
um you know they haven't taken as we
said yesterday running back in round one
since richard mendenhall in 2008 they
went to the super bowl that year but
richard mendenhall didn't have the kind
of impact they need from a running back
if that's where they go there was a back
and forth yesterday between coach mike
tomlin and a reporter on the question of
who's in charge on draft day have a
listen
how exclusive is the decision making
from the process to youtube or mr rooney
and if you guys go outside that
exclusivity in terms of maybe bringing
in a coordinator or anyone else to get a
little bit more
i guess advice on a guy that you might
do mr rooney's the boss
but i mean that's the final decision
though i mean between you guys i mean
i guess how does that process work when
this just say player 8 comes up on the
board thursday night you guys are going
to select how's that process
seriously kevin and i have worked so
well and so long together that we can
kind of communicate non-verbally
in those in those moments but at the end
of the day
our rooney's the boss
two important points there first of all
i think we have a guest simsism in
exclusivity or something like that i
whatever it was it didn't sound right to
me from the reporter not from tomlin
secondly hey i like the fact that we are
evolving to the point where it is
getting out that the owners have a hell
of a lot more influence especially in
round one than we realize they like to
be able to stir
the stew but say hi i'm oh that's not my
spoon that's not me i don't meddle
look when you're talking about major
selections and key points in the future
of a franchise
at a minimum
you're making sure that when you run
that name past the owner the owner
doesn't make a face at a minimum you're
doing that agreed and and uh art
rooney's always he's always been
involved that the families it's the
family business that's right they've
always been involved they are not
absentee landlords they are there with
their sleeves rolled up doing the work
and running the show oh and it's worked
for the past 50 years so they're going
to keep doing it yeah right the it's the
family business this is not like hey we
just stop in every now and then and hey
what's how's the draft going everything
you know i would think the rooney family
like the mara family who's also the
family business type there
you know they're there every day they're
always around they know who the
conversation's around as far as the guys
that are already the handful of guys
they might pick there at pick 24 24 or
something like that so they're very
aware of those situations and i would
think in those type of situations mike
to your point is just like tomlin
colbert they're sitting there
hey you know oh okay hey mr rooney we're
getting down here to our pick
we we got these two guys right here we
were kind of thinking this guy because
we you know he fits what we need to do
and blah blah blah and they make their
case and they make sure he signs off on
it and you know i'm sure there's times
where he's been like well and and he
might go another way but i think that's
pretty
you know
pretty normal protocol uh and you're
right it's kind of fun that it's it's
finally getting out there that these
owners are do have a little more say
than than what we believe
and there are some owners that are a lot
more involved than we realize and look
jerry jones made himself to gm back in
1989. back before
the internet back before talk radio is
what it is now i think if an owner tried
to do that today they would be shouted
down vilified and ridiculed but i think
there are plenty of owners who wield
that power
quietly behind the scenes for a variety
of reasons one of my favorite sayings
the only thing better than being rich
and famous is being rich the more you
are in the fray the more notorious you
become the more hated you become by the
fans it's always good to have somebody
else who's your fall guy that you can
fire if your meddling blows up and i
think there's a lot of owners who who
have that spoon in the stew
and they they reserve the right to say
that's not my spoon
and aren't rooney's far closer to jerry
jones
than others but i think to some degree
they all they all
especially big time picks top 10 picks
quarterback picks they why wouldn't you
yeah why wouldn't you that's one of the
privileges of owning the team and that's
the face of your franchise that's that's
your money maker ultimately it's a
business right the owner better feel
good about who that business is being
entrusted to yeah that's right and you
know what you know why why wouldn't you
you know to the other side of that if
you're the coach or gm make sure the
owner's happy with the pick or hey we're
down to what do you think about
these two or three guys that's important
to their job security as well uh this
this pittsburgh one's interesting
because again they're a team that i
think we both look at and go they're
they're kind of close they really are
and
i mean it's really when you look at the
roster it's rebuild the o line and get a
running game
and that's where i go back to this is i
mean again if there was a quarterback on
the board what would you do this year
yeah trade down you would or what if you
know or what if there's the quarterback
there yeah and you know there's a really
good old lineman on the board too that
you know is gonna you know help your
football team and help that running game
and big ben be you know maybe a tom
brady type story here uh
that that's where it does get you know
very interesting and intriguing as far
as this drafts concern with pittsburgh
depends on the gap between nato lyman
and the guy that i think i can get lower
yeah that's not that big of a gap trade
down and use the other pick on another
line more lottery tickets more guys who
can come in and help us win yeah
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports